le village malheureusement a été
complètement détruit d'ailleurs si vous
y allez vous ne verrez plus qu'un tas de
ruines
il ya eu près de 50 morts ces personnes
je les connaissais je les avait mariés
j'avais baptiser leurs enfants alors je
suis un peu sous le choc parce que quand
20 30 40 ou 50 ami meurt c'est forcément
un drame intérieur et une douleur
profonde
c'est sûr nous aurons certainement des
difficultés à nous reprendre pour
repartir
[Musique]
j'ai vécu le tremblement de terre de
1972 et de 1997 celui de l' aquila que
nous avons ressenti ici parce que nous
sommes relativement proche
mais pour moi ils n'ont pas eu cette
violence cette fois ci par contre il
semble que le tremblement de terre a
suivi une ligne une ligne maudite comme
pescara détruites et à côté il ya un
village vezzano qui n'est qu'à 500
mètres environ
totalement inde m
rien ne s'est écroulé alors ce sont des
phénomènes que moi du moins je n'arrive
pas à comprendre
la science peut-elle expliquer ces
étranges phénomènes les montagnes se
sépare en deux et vous avez des séismes
successifs qui court du sud au nord
l'un après l'autre à des semaines et des
mois d'intervalle créant des failles des
failles très connue des failles que vous
pouvez voir et ben les façades
montagneuse dans ces régions qui ont
connu le plus fort séisme
depuis des centaines d'années
ces failles ont été brisées une par une
créant une brèche
plus au nord le long de l'axé principal
dès monza pneus en italie
ce n'est ni la première ni la dernière
fois que l'italie connaît un fort
tremblement de terre
entre le 26 octobre et le 3 novembre une
dizaine de séismes superficiels avec des
magnitudes 4,5 à 6,5 ont frappé en série
la région de macerata
ils se sont produits dans une faille
sismique entre la zone touchée par le
séisme du mois d'août et l'ombrie une
zone frappée en 1997 les failles se
développent et le processus de
destruction se poursuit 298 personnes
sont mortes dans le tremblement de terre
on estime à près de 2,5 milliards
d'euros le montant total des dommages
[Musique]
des magistrats italiens ont ouvert une
enquête afin de vérifier si les
entreprises de construction avaient
passé outre les réglementations anti
sismique lors de la restauration de
bâtiments publics comme une école à
amath reach est réduite en miettes lors
du tremblement de terre
[Musique]